this morning novak djokovic's lawyers
are defending him from a second attempt
to throw him out of australia the tennis
superstar is there to play next week's
australian open claiming an exemption to
strict coveted vaccination laws the
country's immigration minister canceled
his visa overnight saying it was in the
public interest now the issue is back in
court charlie daggett is watching the
back and forth for us charlie good
morning
good morning to you vlad yes that
emergency court hearing wrapped up just
moments ago where a judge has delayed
the deportation at least until a new
hearing is held on sunday just one day
before the tournament begins the
government's decision to revoke his visa
came down just hours after the
australian open defending champion hit
the courts to get in some practice the
world number one initially had his visa
revoked last week because he hadn't been
vaccinated only for that to be
overturned by a judge on monday
he then confessed to breaking the rules
saying his agent gave incorrect
information on his immigration form uh
he met with a journalist in serbia back
in december despite having tested
positive for kovid which he called an
error of judgment today his lawyer said
the decision to revoke his visa is based
on the premise that his presence in the
country could excite anti-vax sentiment
those are their words not that he's a
risk to public health he's been ordered
to be detained from tomorrow morning
until that hearing on sunday that will
determine whether he'll be able to play
so the game is still on but at the
moment advantage australia vlad
all right charlie all right
yeah that's a nice way to sing out there
charlie yes it is uh so what do we think
the judge is gonna do
i think he's not gonna let him play i
mean
wouldn't it be interesting can you
imagine if novak djokovic had said
listen i made a mistake i broke the
rules i'm dropping out i'll do better
next time i'm so sorry i can't imagine
it
no i can't imagine either but tony just
think of the message that would have
sent because to me some things and i'm
not pollyanna i want to see a good
tennis game too
some things are bigger than tennis and
the message that it sends if he's
allowed to play when he admits he broke
the rules he's walking around with
people knowing that he's positive
the the the answers on his form were not
correct he knows that too it isn't right
so the argument from the government is
is interesting it's not that he's going
to be a health danger it's that he might
incite anti-vac sentiment in the country
and then and then he broke the rules too
they were talking about in the beginning
that he also broke the rules that's
right that's right we'll see how it
plays out
i think it's going to be very
interesting to see what australia does
never i don't think serena
serena was wearing a cat suit during the
french open back in 2016 i believe and
french tennis officials said she
couldn't wear that remember she was
wearing it because she had suffered
blood clots uh as of new mom and they
said if you wear it you cannot place a
very different
talking sports betting at 7 30 with dana
jacobson people will be placing bets on
this one for sure well what do you think
she's going to do what do you think
they're just i think they're going to
let them stay you do yeah that's right
uh i think they're probably not going to
let him stay so we'll see how it plays
out